regardez est-ce que vous avez vu cette
vidéo de philippe etchebest voilà
puisque je réalise également philippe
etchebest qui a poussé un très très gros
coup de gueule aujourd'hui philippe
etchebest 1 le cuisinier top chef a bien
entendu et il était vénéré et regardez
mon accord à regarder c'est bien entendu
on agrandit la vidéo allez on y va
que je trouve on peut la voir vidéo sauf
que moi j'aurais voulu entendre le mot
confinement il est extrêmement important
aujourd'hui que chacun et chacune reste
chez soi pour éviter la propagation de
l'épidémie
restez chez vous on sans penser au
personnel médical qui galèrent et qui va
galérer encore pendant un petit moment
alors plus vite on sortira de ces crises
et mieux on se portera
voilà philippe etchebest donc qui a fait
qui a poussé un gros gros coup de gueule
philippe etchebest
est ce que vous comprenez le coup de
gueule de philippe est chouette et je
vous pose la question vous ici c'est le
débat du soir voilà est-ce que vous
trouvez que les français ont été un
petit peu léger on était un petit peu
inconscient avec tout ce qui s'est passé
mathieu et gilles mathieu non c'est non
pas chaud pas de soi des français quand
inconscient je trouve que depuis le
début c'est par les biens force je
trouve que c'est le début c'est le
gouvernement qui est inconscient et ce
que je ne supporte pas moins lorsque
l'on entend depuis depuis quelques jours
de la part de du président macron et du
premier ministre
c'est que tous leurs discours sont faits
pour nous culpabiliser vous sortez trop
dans la rue au canal saint martin vous
êtes trop près les uns des autres
vous vous ne prenez pas conscience de la
catastrophe
pardon mais c'est pas nous les
responsables ça fait trois semaines
qu'on nous dit sortez dans la rue
ne paniquez pas ne cédez pas à la
panique exactement comme nous a fait le
coup pour terrorisme par amalgame la vie
reprend et tout ça et tout ça pendant
trois semaines on nous a demandé d'avoir
une vie normale on nous a demandé de pas
paniquer et du jour au lendemain on nous
culpabilise en nous disant c'est vous
les fautifs et maintenant si on en est
là c'est de votre faute ça me fait
penser exactement alors en moins grave
le scandale du diesel pendant des années
achetez diesel acheter diesel et un
lundi matin vendée tous deux diesel
c'est une catastrophe et les gens se
retrouvent des bagnoles qui valait plus
rien et se sont retrouvé ruiné
ok un moment c'est vraiment fatiguant
nous ça fait trois semaines qu'on avait
des médecins et qu'on était là et qu'on
disait est ce que c'est pas grave et
qu'on nous rassurait et maintenant on
nous victimise alors que macro nous dise
où le premier ministre c'est grave ce
qui se passe je peux l'entendre mais
à chaque fois que c'est de notre faute
et que comme on ne respecte pas les
consignes comme des mauvais élèves
vous n'allez plus au resto vous ne
respectez pas les consignes maintenant
vous restez chez vous et on nous punit
comme des mômes
alors qu'on nous a dit linverse et moi
ce côté me sentir effectivement coupable
alors que c'est eux les coupables
je trouve que c'est vraiment minable de
la part du gouvernement voilà alors on
est en direct enrichir et vous réagissez
aussi la tuant sur twitter voilà ou bien
voilà vous nous envoyez des messages
comme vous pouvez parce que sur un stade
ou sinon oui et gilles verdez alors
gilbert des ce que tu es d'accord avec
mathieu pas du tout je suis totalement à
l'opposé et on fera éventuellement les
comptes à la fin plus tard mais dire que
le gouvernement voilà les coupables ça
ne me sens pas responsable
on peut être en désaccord avec les choix
du gouvernement on peut dire que le
gouvernement a tâtonné voir nous a fait
aller voter aux élections moi je me sens
berne et j'ai été voté aux élections et
puis après on nous dit fallait pas voter
on reporte le deuxième tour mais malgré
tout ça malgré tout ça mathieu à tort il
ya une responsabilité individuelle et
collective chacun même si le
gouvernement dit tout et son contraire
chacun savait qu'il ne fallait pas
sortir donc les gens qui sont sortis sur
le bord des canaux dans les parcs et
jardins ce jour-là par qui d'ailleurs
aurait dû fermer n'ont pas été
responsable c'est pas bien d'avoir fait
ça on peut pas dire oui alors on se
mathieu gilles genève mais dieu non non
non tu les poser laissez moi finir vous
avez été très long vous exonérer les
gens de responsabilité en disant c'est
la faute du gouvernement
non ces gens qui ont été dans les parcs
en famille qui font la cohue pour dans
les supermarchés ne sont pas
responsables il faut faire attention un
maître un mètre cinquante de distance de
sécurité on leur a dit pendant 3 nov
c'est une petite grille donnant rien de
plus si l'on ne s'attaque pas à pas les
derniers jours avec l'élection à voter
dans presque ce qu'on a entendu on a vu
même des mecs qui disaient ouais mais
c'est pas pour nous c'est pour les
personnes âgées même même quand on
entend ça c'est inadmissible
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'on
peut voir des personnes âgées décédées
parce que j'ai vu des mecs dans les
parkings façon on n'est pas concerné
c'est pour les personnes âgées c'est
inadmissible de dire ça alors je suis
d'accord maintenant on est tous pareils
sert il ya ce qu'on entend est ce qu'on
voit et on est tous pareils ce qu'on
entend ça nous dit rien si demain je te
dis cyril attention tu peux avoir un
cancer ça te fait peur mais voilà
maintenant si demain je t'emmène voir ce
que c'est qu'un cancer la chimie ou les
difficultés de ces gens tu vas le
comprend
je pensais que déjà le gouvernement
devrait nous montrer des images pour
nous montrer ce que c'est que la
difficulté c'est une sorte de cancer des
poumons généralisée qui fait qu'on a des
gamins des jeunes même jim et moi même
me l'a dit j'ai déjeuné avec lui ya une
semaine qui sont sous respirateur
artificiel
c'est faudra le montrer sur montrer aux
gens ce qu'ils risquent il sortirait
déjà moins dans la rue mais ça on nous
cache
mais on nous cache tout regarde hier le
discours de macron il a tenu 25 minutes
sortir une fois le mot confinement
n'ayez pas peur des mots ici c'est la
guerre c'est il faut il faut dès lors
tous les ânes il a dit la guerre la
vierge et dernière chose série dure
joueuse elle est votée dimanche avec un
ami je te jure que c'est vrai dans le 6e
arrondissement si nous regarde
honte au maire du 6e arrondissement il
n'y avait aucun gel dans le 6e qui dans
sixième sens vers quoi alors pardon je
sers pas que te dire c'est dans ces
barreaux dispensés ya plusieurs d'euros
peut voter je suis allé voter dans le
sival on est allés voter en sixième et
il n'y avait aucun aucun gel sais c'est
pas une honte on nous demande de sortir
de sortir nos personnages et leurs
études ils me disent on regarde on va
regarder ce que j'ai dit regardez
regardez hier emmanuel macron regarde ce
qu'il a dit on peut pas dire qu'ils
déconnent la quotidien on est en guerre
on est en guerre on regarde et on revoit
wimpey le mot confinement en guerre nous
sommes en guerre
nous sommes en guerre nous sommes en
guerre nous sommes en guerre
nous sommes en guerre oui voilà donc il
a erré voyez ce qu'il y est on est en
guerre on est en guerre on engage il
mais mathieu dit n'importe quoi là la
france est une nation indisciplinés
indisciplinés nous sommes indisciplinés
hélas alors on est indiscipliné parce
que l'histoire les gaulois contre les
romains nous ont rendus indisciplinés il
ya eu des études récemment de l' ocde
sur 79 pays on est l'autre en classe nos
enfants sont les troisièmes plus
indisciplinés on est indiscipliné ont
donc on a fait n'importe quoi mais c'est
pas une raison parce qu'on est
indiscipliné pour aller se balader dans
des parcs alors qu'un coronavirus
mathieu en disant ça vous dédouaner les
gens de l'immense conneries qu'ils ont
fait et ça ce ne peut pas tolérer c'est
pas acceptable
il fallait pas y aller il ya eu de
propagation du virus à cause de ça cyril
le dit après on est ensemble et puis on
va contaminer d'autres gens donc c'est
une responsabilité collective d'avoir
fait ça
cette collecte est bonne